que no decir de ella compañeros aquí se
refieren a ella como La reina del rock
esa leyenda musical imparable La
historia estadounidense musical son
algunas de las referencias que están
haciendo hoy a ella una mujer que nació
hace 83 años en Génesis en los 50 se
lanzó con su hermana a cantar en clubs
nocturnos en San Luis en Missouri fue
allí precisamente donde conoció a su
esposo quien le dio el sobrenombre
artístico de Tina Turner Y a partir de
ahí todos conocéis esa historia de
éxitos encima de los escenarios que duró
hasta el 2013 año en el que decidió
retirarse lo hizo como decíais en Zurich
en Suiza allí llevaba varios años
luchando contra algunas enfermedades que
hoy pues han apagado su voz pero desde
luego no su música desde que se ha
conocido la noticia de su muerte aquí la
mayoría de las cadenas han interrumpido
su programación para explicar lo que ha
ocurrido en la radio estamos escuchando
constantemente sus grandes éxitos y en
televisión estamos viendo testimonios de
amigos familiares artistas que
convivieron con ella a lo largo de su
vida que recuerdan su poderosa voz su
estilo artístico sin igual su
maravillosa puesta en escena Pues todos
recuerdos que desde luego se quedarán
siempre con nosotros igual que su música
porque como digo se ha pagado ella pero
desde luego no su legado musical